let's get to some questions every day is
just very heavy negative news from the
political world so maybe we'll take a
little bit of a break from that and
answer a few questions to wrap up the
week Kelly wrote in she said so David
have you gone minimalist after
recommending that movie about minimalism
and interviewing that dude yes so I
recommended a movie called the
minimalist it was about minimalism we
interviewed one of the stars of that
film etc etc have I gone minimalist I've
not made any drastic changes since I
recommended that film and we did the
interview but I am trying to just
minimize the amount of stuff that I have
and I had some friends visit last
weekend and I realized as I was sort of
like getting there the guest bed ready
and going through closets to grab a few
things there's just so many items lying
around and a lot of them I just don't
use and I am actively trying to get rid
of stuff when I look and I see I've got
old tea cups and plates that I just I've
never used since I moved to Boston and
in addition to that it's a number that
exceeds the number of people I could
even have in my apartment right like the
number of cups I have at this point far
exceeds the max number of people I could
ever even have in my apartment so when
would I ever need that number of cups I
want to start getting rid of stuff yeah
one of the strategies that Ryan
Nicodemus proposed to us for getting rid
of stuff was to just get rid of one
thing every day yeah and I guess you can
also the second day get rid of two
things for Thursday three things excited
off by the end of the month would you go
along with something like that I would
definitely try it I am trying to set
aside time on weekend to find things I
can get rid of and like last weekend i
said i have a bunch of clothes that I'm
keeping that I don't actually think I'm
wearing I went through my entire
wardrobe and I ended up deciding hey you
know what I think I'm keeping some of
these clothes to feel like I have more
options but the reality is I'm probably
rotating the same 15 shirts on the show
a lot of these shirts I've not worn on
the show button-down shirts for years
I'm going to donate these I'm going to
donate these I'm going to donate old
jeans that I say I'll keep it around in
case I'm painting one of these days I'm
painting a wall these have paint stains
on them I might need them been a very
long time since I put them on I it's
going i'm getting rid of it I really
just think clothes
one of the biggest barriers for me to
observing a minimalist lifestyle because
I guess essentially you only need maybe
a couple pairs of pants maybe a couple
pairs of shoes and you know 10 or so
tough but you want to have some variety
and what you're wearing and yeah even
though it causes clutter at times and
can be a hassle with laundry and that
sort of thing you want to change up what
you're wearing every day no doubt and
then the other thing that I have been
actively doing is trying to go
minimalist when it comes to technology
and organization of files right like
cleaning up my desktop on my computer
and on my laptop going through our
dropbox folder and just getting rid of
stuff if we really haven't used it for
over a year do I really need that this
type of fig and it is effective I mean
it's just great to get a lot of clutter
out consolidating a lot of the stuff
that I work on a day-to-day basis taking
it from my calendar task list and saying
these don't need to be ten different
tasks let me get rid of three that I
don't need to be doing and put the other
seven as a subgroup of one action that I
really am trying to do here and let's
just start to clear out that's
interesting because when you think of
the minimalist lifestyle you think of
the possessions that are physical that
are in the room that are ramping up your
space but if you're spending hours a day
at work on your laptop or computer I
mean you want to have that organized as
well and we'll just be able to access
what you need any given day my email
inbox is a big example of minimalism I
mean basically I've decided rather than
just kind of like looking at email a
bunch of times throughout the day and
then looking at something but then
leaving it to do later I'm going with
the David Allen getting things done idea
of if it takes under two minutes set a
time where you're going through your
email and any email that requires under
two minutes to deal with whether it's
getting a file updating a spreadsheet
and sending it back whatever you do it
immediately because you're just wasting
time if you read it and then you leave
it and then hours later you go back and
say oh I'm going to deal with this now
let me reread it and now I'll get what I
need just get it done that's my strategy
at this point I mean your email is
listed in a way that's chronological too
so it's really not listed in a way that
orders how much time it will take to
dedicate to each one of those email
absolutely so I mean yeah I mean that
could be tough yeah and the move is
again you go in
logical order takes under two minutes
you do it if it's going to take longer I
make a note my calendar and deal with it
later so yeah I'm trying to do it I'm uh
somewhat successfully I would say